there are two things that the federal
government is supposed to guarantee to
every state in the union number one a
republican form of government not
republican party but republican form of
government and number two they're
supposed to protect every state from
invasion well when you have an
administration like we see with the
bible administration that has abdicated
their constitutional duty and
responsibility to protect the
sovereignty of texas and the sovereignty
of the united states of america texas
has a
1254-mile border with a foreign country
and it is not just an everyday foreign
country it's a destabilized foreign
country and we see this transnational
narco criminal terrorist organization
known as the cartels really running
things along our border
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
retired army lieutenant colonel chairman
of the republican party of texas and
candidate for governor of texas
alan west welcome back to the reuben
report
good to be with you dave and merry
christmas i have to make one correction
i stepped down from being the chairman
uh back in june right before i announced
the run for governor because i didn't
want any conflict of interest but uh
everything is going very well here in
texas
well merry christmas to you and i like
being corrected by the guest on the very
first sentence of an interview i feel
we're not gonna edit i always tell my
guests we don't edit for content so i
like it you're setting the tone uh i
appreciate the fact check on that how
are you my friend you know i realized
like a minute before we started here
that we've actually never done the
one-on-one you've been on the show once
you were on with chad robichaud we were
talking about all the work that you guys
do with veterans but we've actually
never done the one-on-one that was a
couple years ago you've had an
interesting uh couple years
yeah it's been
yeah it has been an interesting couple
years i you know by by the grace of god
i probably should not be here because
last year memorial day weekend i had an
accident on my motorcycle 75 miles an
hour on interstate highway and uh you
know the fact that i'm still alive is
very uh very great and so it's a
pleasure to be here with you and
everything and i'm down here in
livingston texas at dfw post 8568 and i
love coming you know getting out of the
big cities and getting down to the small
rural areas and especially being with
veterans what a what a great thing to do
is as you know as we go into the holiday
season also yeah and you guys do some
tremendous work with veterans before we
get into everything you're doing now and
why you're running for governor and of
texas and everything else uh could we
just do the quick uh two minute bio on
you and your story your service that
sort of thing just so those those that
don't know you will fully know you and
then we'll go from there
well i got to tell you when you think
about the american dream and everything
that america offers to each and every
one of us i call it the equality of
opportunity not the quality of outcomes
you know 60 years ago i was born in a
blacks only hospital in the inner city
of atlanta georgia i grew up in the same
neighborhood they gave us dr marlissa
king jr there in atlanta
my dad was a world war ii corporal
united states army and he served this
country at a time when he was not seen
equal to everyone in a segregated army
my mother did 25 years plus civilian
service with the marine headquarters in
atlanta my older brother was an
infantryman and marine corps and was
wounded in vietnam at the age of 15 my
dad challenged me to be the first
officer in our family and on 31 july
1982 i was commissioned as a second
lieutenant at the university of
tennessee i served 22 years active duty
service for the united states army as a
field artillerman also as a paratrooper
13 different countries three different
combat zones
the story for our family doesn't end
there my
nephew who is my older brother son he is
now lieutenant colonel in the united
states army continuing to serve i've
been married for 32 years i have a great
wife she's really the brain trust of
this this couple she has an mba and a
phd and i met her when she was a
business professor at kansas state
university we had two daughters aubry
and austin 28 and 24 and six months ago
we became grandparents to an incredible
little grandson by the name of jackson
bernard so that's pretty much so my life
and you know i had a great opportunity
to serve in the state of florida as a
united states congressman
and back in 2004 i got the opportunity
to come back to texas my last duty sign
was fort hood texas and so here i am uh
now running to be the governor of the
state of texas
well you definitely handled the resume
question well so uh let's talk a little
bit about the states because you
mentioned the the sort of big two or the
shining stars at least from where i'm at
at the moment as you know i'm in crazy
los angeles california as we tape this
uh but you mentioned florida where you
were a congressman you're running for
governor in texas
are you
sort of pleased to see the way the
states have gone in different directions
at this point that the federalist system
is sort of working when you see hubs of
freedom like florida and texas and i'll
throw tennessee in there and a couple
other states while you watch some of the
blue states
kind of crumble
well the interesting thing is i think we
need to reassert that sense of
federalism and what we see as far as
that understanding of the 10th amendment
where it says that those powers not
delegated to the federal government are
reserved to the states and to the people
and that's where we have a huge
constitutional crisis here in the state
of texas because article 4 section 4 of
the constitution there are two things
that the federal government is supposed
to guarantee to every state in the union
number one a republican form of
government not republican party but
republican form of government and number
two they're supposed to protect every
state from innovation well when you have
an administration like we see with the
bidet administration that has abdicated
their constitutional duty and
responsibility to protect the
sovereignty of texas and the sovereignty
of the united states of america texas
has a
1254-mile border with a foreign country
and it is not just an everyday foreign
country it's a destabilized foreign
country and we see this transnational
narco criminal terrorist organization
known as the cartels really running
things along our border and so the
founding fathers and their brilliance
gave the state the ability to be able to
protect itself if the federal government
advocated that and so i think that
that's one of the things we see here in
texas and many of the other red states
is to once again reassert that ideal of
federalism uh this the federal
government is supreme over the states by
the supremacy clause but it has to be
that they're doing things pursuant
they're up to the constitution and i
would challenge anyone when we see this
by the administration they're not doing
too many things pursuant to the
constitution
is the border issue you think that's the
number one issue on texans minds i mean
it's a little hard to gauge because on
one hand you can sort of only see the
videos on fox or online mainstream won't
cover it and then it makes it a little
hard to see well what is the average
person seeing do they even know what
they're voting on because they're not
seeing it depending on what news they
watch
well i will tell you that you talk to
people down here in texas and especially
you talk to people on the border
counties they will tell you that's the
number one thing and i think that it
really came to a forefront nationally as
an issue when we saw those airplanes
that landed in the middle of the night
in westchester county new york that had
illegal immigrant minor children and
those planes took off from texas and we
also know that there are planes that
have been landing in florida where i
think you may be looking to come we want
you to come here to texas i don't want
to go anywhere but who told you to make
the hard sell man
i'm gonna make you an offer you can't
refuse but you know we we've seen those
planes land in florida we've seen those
plants land in tennessee and how
interesting there are those planes are
landing in red states those planes are
landing in suburban areas but most uh
definitely we need to realize that the
united states of america right now has
an all-time high in drug overdoses over
100 000 of our young people drug
overdoses and other where's that coming
from the fentanyl and how is fentanyl
getting to the united states of america
from china down to mexico across the
border here so we got a drug trafficking
crisis we have a human and sex
trafficking crisis texas is the number
one state in america for human sex
trafficking dallas and houston uh maybe
you don't want to move into dallas but
we can talk about suburbs but dallas and
houston are the top two cities in the
country for sex trafficking and we know
about the public health crisis think
about this dave i mean we've got a
federal government that's telling us law
abiding american citizens what we have
to get injected into our bodies but
people are coming across 200 000 a month
and no one is telling them they have to
have anything injected in their body so
we have a public health crisis as well
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell